what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch cobra kai season three
episode eight today
if you haven't done so already make sure
to subscribe click that notification
bell to get notified when our next cobra
kai reaction is up while you're at it if
you end up enjoying our video please hit
that like button i did
want to give a very sincere thank you to
everyone who has been following us over
at our patreon page i know i've plugged
at the top of every one of these videos
but we really are appreciative
of everyone who's been able to go out
there and show their support over our
patreon if you haven't been that's
a-okay but i do want to give a special
thanks to everyone that has been
checking out all our extra content when
you do these tv show reactions you know
it's a real
ballpark game of uh i don't know which
ones will be monetized and which ones
are not once in a while we are lucky
every once while we're not
either way these do take a good amount
of time to assemble so to everyone that
has shown their support there it really
has helped supplemented you know the
ones that haven't been monetized so
thank you guys so much
anywho let's go ahead and watch the show
we all work together the reason we learn
karate
is to show the world
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh triple senseis
i feel like eagle fang would be my jam
the perfect blend
if shannon's still in rehab i just
wanted to make sure someone was here to
pick him
oh damn priest is my problem
not anymore he's made it crystal clear
that he is everyone's problem i'm going
to have to be the one that's going to
clean up your mess
what are you guys going to work together
we're together like the second episode
your whole life you've been striking
first you never once considered that
maybe you should think
i like that line seriously
my two dads you always have a home in
the audience
with me at eagle corner
fake fans fake fans
come on robbie oh please don't go to
covert kyrah
oh sorry i'm sorry no i'm sorry i should
have been watching
me too anyway i'll let you get back to
your friends
not my friends anymore not after what
they did you guys ah
you guys can date now make out make out
okay
right here in the front of the school do
you think enough time has passed for us
to
be friends again more more more than
that
oh oh my god oh my god whoa dmitry
doing study work
for that's what i'm talking about
dimitri
like i would ever date this freak
she means freak like you know freaky
i thought it was gonna be season four
yeah
did you like having your arm broken
dimitri because if you defend like that
you're gonna be right back in that cast
before you know it
uh that's not really miagi don't talk if
he didn't get his arm broken
he wouldn't be hooking up
[Laughter]
it's a complex world we live in there's
a problem with the whole tournament
oh that's face you're next does my
nickname gotta carry over from
oh miguel miguel
don't hurt yourself miguel careful
twisting
careful with those twists
[Music]
oh they canceled the all valley oh
no not wanting to foster a culture of
violence after the whole
practice at the school it's it's an
overcorrection this is topical
oh keep your politics
there's one person that can convince the
city to overturn their decision
it's a two-time champion oh [ __ ] all
three of them will have to talk to the
board huh
oh probably maybe on some level this is
for the best
no go fight the committee you're not
actually going to let them cancel the
old valley tournament are you dad
i don't know sam no the tournament gets
canceled that sends a message to the
whole valley that we're the bad guys
you need to tell them what karate means
to you have you started to help yourself
oh
they're all gonna go there
it's not like you're even gonna fight
anyway of course i was
what miguel miguel you don't think i can
do it you almost hurt yourself with one
kick
look you already proved you could win
and i need to prove it again oh
dude you're not broken miguel you said
you'd always be on my side he
is he is you know
[Music]
the dodgers are on top
he'll be fine once he's watched his time
i'm robbie keane fill out this form
we'll call your name on a probation
officer's right that's where he got this
haircut
is cree's going to show up here he's
probably lives here
oh [ __ ] yep he's going to go to cobra
kai isn't he
yeah go ahead don't send me straight
back to doobie
[Music]
beat her
thank you yeah starting the fight and
you for finishing it
peace she'll turn on you just like
miguel you don't know what you're
talking about
and why are we both here oh damn sam's
gonna hook up with miguel this episode
[Music]
based on life experience i appreciate
you putting miguel's safety first
but let him fight
you've done so much for miguel you made
him smile again
and he won't forget that and neither
will i
let's get it on i see how much you care
for miguel and i realize now you were
just as hurt as i was
but i know he won't get hurt again
because you're his sensei
and there are other miguels out there
who need you in their corner
clones you have to save the tournament
oh no no yeah
i don't know how i'm gonna do that by
working with daniel larusso
are you doing what you do right you
fight the committee
like you're fighting the urge to kiss
right now
i'm hearing the city wants to rename
manholes maintenance coverage what a
bunch of
[ __ ] twitter was just the thing
birds used to say
fighting for the old valley what about
you you gonna be from your diary
yeah i don't need notes shoot from the
head
oh god this is gonna be a disaster
would like to speak first
no damn here we go i'm retired army
captain john crease
thank you for your service boy
it was an honor to serve i'm sure
why are my students being penalized
because of the violence perpetrated by
miyagido now wait just one time don't
guys guys
i apologize councilwoman roberts but
this man council
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is his greatest i'm sorry but this
guy is selling you a bad bill of goods
just a few weeks ago my students were
injured by a bunch of his cobra kites
guys this isn't gonna help you this is
gonna
be and who started that fight you're out
of control daughter no
a man you're like my daughter i've had
to file a restraining order against her
oh
god maybe i should make the call to the
authorities
oh i'm leaving i'm leaving
okay but that man is a lunatic
they've done such a good job on this man
john lawrence eagle fan cry
look this man is a thief and a lion and
he put a live cobra in my dealership
yeah this is really gonna help you guys
i'm all of your mom
miguel say it all in spanish miguel
he's the one that got kicked off the
second floor
coma coma i'm afraid you don't
understand yes he does
we're the ones fighting and we want a
place where we can compete
fairly and safely we clearly have an
anger bro
joey's going to be a kid wants to steal
your lunch money i give you a wedgie
or give you a swirly a swirly when you
uh dunk someone's head in the toilet
pretty funny actually
sensei instead of burying your heads in
the sand
and pretending that bullying doesn't
exist what you need to do is teach kids
how to defend themselves
physically and mentally dude i love this
absolutely sometimes the scars you can't
see are the ones that hurt the most
oh guys david crease is a little proud
i don't know where i would be today or
who i would be today
if it wasn't for my sensei
and specifically not the guy right
it's called the all valley because it's
for everyone to give everyone the chance
to show what they can do and we deserve
that chance mcgowan
shut her down to be honest i don't get
the valleys
fascinating
the all valley under 18 tournament is
officially
back on way to go you two
ah now where's robbie to just stand
there in the corner
i guess we all got what we want someone
needs to have a tape recorder
and a video camera everything
work together guys come on don't make us
wait till episode 10.
oh my god it's about to happen it's
about to happen
and robbie's going to come back just
looking to meditate here or something
do you guys actually do karate here it
looks like breathing exercises
oh it's not badass enough all right
you're looking to take on the champion
they're going to have love karate oh
dude he's kicking all right
[Music]
are you always standing in the corner at
the wrong time robbie
i stopped writing because you never
answered yeah well it's kind of hard to
write back in between getting my face
busted it's not a fall
stay out i don't think i will oh
crap he's joining cobra kai
robbie don't yeah dude you paralyzed
that kid don't do it
you two deserve each other there's no
robbie's going to be standing there
just assume hey he's going to be sad
assuming he's there at all times i heard
what happened at the meeting
ah you should have seen him hard on his
sleeve saying what needed to be said
believe me had nothing to do with that
you had everything to do with that
[Music]
three seasons in the bank
dice johnny can't afford a lot of
tickets i was gonna say that's a
few thousand dollars worth of a kiss
right there crap
robbie's gonna show up oh ravi don't
break my heart man ah [ __ ] you robbie
it's robbie isn't it
ugh robbie robbie
sensei craig
robbie we're gonna keep this short
because um
in real time we're all the real rejects
we're gonna film the next episode
so we're going to keep this really short
so we can get a little bit ahead on some
other things you got to be editing as
well this show just keeps teasing you
like are they gonna ban together yet or
not
i gotta admit man that robbie thing is
just so just like
this is the ultimate trademark cliche
this show at this point for me
yeah i'm just like he's going to be
standing there he's going to be standing
even when their baskets are like right
they're going to be standing there yeah
that's the one maybe like actual
complaint i have towards this
like when it comes to those beats at the
very end i'm like ah
damn you just had this scene so that you
could have robbie show up yeah oh
cause his problem son of a [ __ ] get him
to crease but i really do
i mean i thought the episode overall
still is another great i have
literally no qualms with this whole
series it's just so frustrating because
you know what direction it'll go
yeah you know it's like ah crap now he's
gonna be a cobra kai man you just know
it's going down that path
i really love that like town assembly
scene it's
exactly what we go wrong in a situation
like that
yeah where you got this battle of egos
and what i thought i think is so great
of what they're doing is they really
know how to make chris
look sympathetic he uses the war vet
thing
as a way to immediately gain respect and
sympathy he puts on a different cadence
with his voice he chooses his words
correctly
to make himself seem like the
level-headed sound of the voice of
reason
guy and knowing how to provoke people
like danny and amanda in there to make
them seem like they're the crazy ones
you know you go back to that first
episode when the whole school assembly
is getting pissed off at the
miyagi joe you guys are the real bullies
and then he does [ __ ] like this
just to further enhance that that image
that has now been
created around danny larusso and miyagi
doe it's it's a really
smart tactic that this guy has taken on
and uh yeah it just keeps getting to the
point of like what are johnny and him
just gonna finally team up
how are they gonna team up damn it's
taking so long no yeah i absolutely
agree i i love
a moment like that when you have like
three adults who effectively are turned
into children and then the kids have to
step up and truly
be the adults and and like again this
isn't a series that i
expected to get moved by during moments
like that but when miguel is like up
there giving his piece i was actually
getting a little misty and i was like go
buddy go
yeah it's beautiful and yeah i mean to
see the the repercussions on the outside
like it does
add that element of stakes of like would
miguel even be able to compete at all
because he does seem to be experiencing
these physical limitations and while
that wasn't a huge aspect of this
episode i
i like that they brought that in as well
as a struggle for him
sort of father-son kind of friction
between him and johnny to further
solidify that relationship yeah this
episode
seems like that was the heart and then
you got a whole bunch of other little
moments like yeah like with the kids at
school
dimitri everything's great you know and
it's funny because like
you know you don't get hardly any of the
cobra kai kids in this episode except
for maybe that
one little exchange with hawk where you
know he just makes that eye contact with
miguel
well you got tori and robbie and robbie
will now be
lead fighter of cobra guy that's right
that's right he's gonna he maybe he will
be the new
hawk and then hawk will be dethroned by
robbie my thing is i think hawk will
have some type of redemption arc
yeah or that robbie will be a part of
cobra kai
and then in season four robbie will
finally get out of
all these schools and he's just gonna
fight this is where i think it's going i
don't know like based off
based off of how they've been setting up
a hawk's random sympathetic like
oh i'm conflicted are you in my quiet
moments i'm conflicted
yeah the moments no one else gets to see
but like robbie they've set up robbie
did just not trust anyone
obviously doesn't trust his dad after
everything he can't trust daniel after
he's the reason he went to juvenile hall
and the one who seemed to talk something
that seemed to benefit him was chris
when he was like you should strike first
and then bam you're
respecting the prison able to survive
you know things like that so
uh like the way they have narratively
drawn but nothing feels random or forced
no other than robbie
showing everything magically appear in
silence like a ninja at
all these particular moments everything
feels like it naturally got here even if
it feels a tad
predictable it still feels natural yeah
they're good at making it feel lived in
absolutely you know in all honesty i i
think miguel and sam belong together
more than
i get robbie's a like oh trust me if i
was in robbie's shoes
yeah at this particular moment if i was
in his position after everything i've
been through being a fugitive having
been cheated on and getting out of jail
and you got this crap happening right
before he
i i get it i would oh i would too would
just be
in his exact emotional state even as
like a 30 year old adult
i'd be in this emotional state however
when i step outside and i think about
relationships and that happens like well
i think miguel and sam just make way
more sense than robbie and sam
so i would i lean more towards that
and i'm and like even the romantic
quality between miguel's mom who i still
refer to as miguel's mom
miguel do you know her name it's okay
i'm not going to say it out loud
it's miguel's mom miguel's mom miguel's
mom and johnny
them striking up the romance again and
that feels natural and
also all this whole thing with um eagle
fang karate
i love the separa it's actually really
funny how this title is
aptly named the good the bad and the
badass yeah johnny's
i'm assuming johnny's is the badass
right yeah daniels is the best
yeah those crazy miyagi kids but you
have the good
with miyagi the bad cobra kai and then
right in the middle is the badass
because they they're tough you know and
i love that opening
i love the opening and then how they
narratively put that together to really
separate the difference in
philosophies and what even makes
johnny's different from cobra kai
that they're tough you know they still
have that badass get it done attitude
but they also really have an established
line
yeah yeah but don't be [ __ ]
don't be bullies there's a line you
don't cross though for me like when i'm
watching
like oh actually dojo i would probably
join would probably be the eagle fang
one
like that's that's the mindset i feel
like i prefer to be on board with
it's like do i meditate do i do personal
development audio and all that yeah i do
so
technically speaking i'm more of a
miyagi doe kind of guy but the one i'd
want to learn from i feel like would be
eagle fang
yeah yeah just to have a little bit more
of that attitude but not too much to the
point where i become a bad person
and you know you feel like you're
probably getting a bit more done without
the whole sort of like oh that's right
muscle memory that's why we're painting
this fence right now
you'll just do karate you'll get the
benefits of that yeah but
even i thought that was a great little
exquisite corpse that they arranged at
the front of the episode yeah
oscillating between all the schools
contrasting and comparing them and
whatnot and really
i thought that was a nice thematic setup
for the last three episodes of the
season
to have the trilogy the try uh have the
trio of teams sort of
right front and center now and i'm
really happy for dimitri at school
my god that was such a rewarding moment
and he got his cast
yeah there you go all right guys cobra
kai you gotta film the next episode
should be up tomorrow so keep a lookout
for that
do you prefer robbie didn't you know
what i'm trying to say robbie
for sam go to sam mcgill yeah they've
had some translations which one
subscribe
click that notification bell hit the
like button last but not least
deonte w tongue punch fart box okay so
my hope for season four
another dojo comes into the play oh yeah
a new threat
and what's it obviously gonna be called
deontay
dion deontay doe no no no that's a
stupid joke
come on guys we know what we're going
for yeah tongue punch fart
punch fart box think of that on a
t-shirt yeah
just a box with a tongue sticking out
and gas
and a fist coming out of the gas that
will be it that would be really cool
that would also be the special maneuver
that'd be the takedown move well in
karate kid world we have the crane
maneuver
you have them you got that that ass man
farting up that fart box maneuver finish
him
yeah you know i mean that would be a
great way to immobilize an opponent you
catch them off guard plus if they have
asthma or something you know that's
disgusting you're disgusting w
tongue punch fart box but that's what i
like about you is you stop at nothing
to win you're a real threat a real
fighter
thanks deontay for being part of a
patreon [ __ ]